yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is round six right around six of
Tata Steel 2016 and it was a pretty good
round I will go through all of the games
as usual in fact I think I could
actually spend more time on those games
if absolutely yeah everything would be
would be covered every detail and
wrinkle but I want to keep the videos at
a reasonable length so I think you will
be well informed afterwards even though
the odd game could certainly treat it
with more care okay let's see we have a
game kayaking alien off here and let's
see what happened here it's a solid the
Catalan and quite surprising hey I can
usually an e4 guy but he's probably so
sick of the Berlin that he switched to
d4 for that event or let's say nany for
in many games yeah check I you know with
the check here going for bogo style and
kayaking place 92 surprising yeah we had
an earlier game alien off I think it was
alien of Tomashevsky where we had the
same position with a lien of being white
and now he repeats it with black but he
does not play c5 even though he had
absolutely nothing as wide against it
and I kind of interesting he plays d5
now of course that is also move in my
book in this position i also had c5 as
it is more was more in in line with the
rest of the repertoire as i did not go
for any d5 based set up just in one case
where I absolutely couldn't couldn't
avoid it yeah d5 of course does make
some sense yeah putting a pawn on d5
with this night on the two being not so
active yeah Bishop g2 castles 903 and p6
one of the lines that black can play em
the hanging poor information that we get
here and that hanging for information
Black is
p that the White Knight is on d too
because there is no pressure on d5 yeah
if it was on c3 mean besides the fact
that right devotee it would help you be
hanging but usually you want the knight
on c3 to put some pressure on the center
and it is not so dangerous on d to black
has a very active position you actually
take stakes and here black is going for
an IQ p position yeah this is not a bad
i QP the bishop on b7 is a little bit
unusual let's say that normally is out
on g4 or a 5 mostly or g4 and this iqp
positions but it is also not totally off
on b7 as it sometimes helps to support a
knife maybe to come here also import
this why does not have proper control
over t4 he tried to regroup his knife
down most nights yeah to this this kind
of setup and this is an interesting try
if a black now takes on you too then y
term has a good position after Knight
takes more takes Bishop takes f6 Yap
here at the end White has the much
better position yeah this is still kind
of kind of tricky but white remains with
a much better position here yeah so just
bishop 83 normally you don't want to
trade so much with the IQ p but here
there's a clear motivation behind it and
this is that trading this bishop on b2
we can see three the dark squares black
always has this counter play idea here
that after pawn comes to d4 this is the
consequence of white not being able to
block that square that black has this
counter play idea with
night coming here yeah nitey form twin
back route d1 or oxy one yeah now we got
those trades and the black is always
active enough 96 is a nice little tactic
but it is at the end just the
simplification takes antiques this gets
traded and now black gets rid of his
pawn yeah it's all a big trade and here
they agree to a drop that will be seven
the position is totally equal so um yeah
a position or a game we're pretty early
on blackhead equalized and after that it
was pretty much yeah again without many
many highlights let's say but sometimes
it happens nothing yeah nothing special
materialize if both sides play very
solidly and without any mistakes yeah
the game Adams went really feature the
night off yeah one of the most popular
openings and as we had discussed earlier
in other games why does struggling with
something substantial against the night
of especially if you want a sharp
position so people tend to switch to
slowish Alliance and g3 is such a line
that Adams us trying here we saw that
early end event and it didn't lead to
much in that game I think Geary editors
black against by here thank you and well
here we get the same structure yeah
black gets in b5 and now both sides
fight for the d5 square straight it and
Knight f6 yeah on typical Sicilian
battle well um yeah White has this
knight on d5 but you cannot maintain
that piece so can exchange is here and
now looky one why it's got the bishop
pair yeah and
strategically speaking it looks kind of
nice even though if Blackwood now play
something normal I rook c8 or something
is probably still round equal and even
though all this is true when VD now has
an interesting when it I think it's nice
that you spotted that idea because it is
not very apparent let's say there's a
tactic and I takes you for that's quite
a funny move what's the point if white
now takes with the bishop on e4 then
after Bishop takes rook takes Queen B 7
it's a double attack now the loose
bishop won't be 6 yeah and hereafter
rookie three let's say Queen takes be
six black is a pretty healthy porn up I
mean okay this is not exactly strong
yeah after let's say thank you coming
here but it's still upon and black can
hope to ya get it win out of that so
instead just winning upon no rook takes
a form is much much more interesting and
what was the point the point is now f5
the rook is attacked and has to go to e3
after which blacks takes on g2 and now
we see what happens with Queen B 7 and
capturing he gets the piece back so king
cakes check hookah 30 sorry was a bit
too quick look at three that's
interesting now after Queen takes there
is screen check and rook air-five and
white gets the pawn back because of the
hanging rook in the corner so black even
had this this dinner intermezzo g5 white
had to go back out of that pin and queen
takes now now after the check king g7
there is no Luke takes at five yeah we
played this after look at five rook
air-five create justice little problem
therefore rook t1 so Knight takes e4
have invidious little trick has negative
a pawn however blacks King position here
is very loose yeah he had to move all
those pawns forward and he's not exactly
exactly strong with this King so I think
Adams position is perfectly okay you
should always have enough counter play
as long as it keeps pieces on and in the
game we can look at this rather quickly
white activate it put pressure on d6 and
the thing is it's very difficult to like
to make any headway so then shuffled
around here and agree to a draw here
yeah it doesn't look very fighting to
just make a draw but there's absolutely
no way forward here yeah black is having
some pressure on f2 white is having
pressure on the six and black king is
very weak so you have a hard time to
change the structure at all and for
black gift if you want to do something
with your porn you have to yeah advance
your pawns and this makes the King even
weaker so it's a pretty logical draw
actually not a bad game I mean
interesting point with Knight takes e4
by then vini but it ultimately needed to
a position that was yeah not not
winnable let's say even though you have
a pawn it's it's difficult to get
anywhere substantial ok next game i want
to check his ding Liren against navara
ding is one of the co-leaders with plus
two after he had beaten kayaking in the
wrong before and let's see what he's
doing against navara navara is not
having such a bad event he had a pretty
tough loss against who you're fine but
played all drawers in the rest of the
games and he had this this winning
opportunity against geary so it's um
yeah he's he's slightly below what he
could have done
in this and this event he should have at
least fifty percent ok we have a VN
shadow brune felt and we'll see 65 again
they play yeah this is the as often
mentioned the most solid way to do it
and difficult currently four wide to
show something we have seen two games in
this event with Queen to a4 and in both
cases a six was a reply and white good
know where Carson tried it against
member tiara for example and had
absolutely nothing yeah ding is going
for the trade the classical continuation
trying to get something in this in this
symmetrical position yeah black played
you six-year this is believed to be the
best continuation something like 96 is
less convincing white has quite often
chances to like take on c6 for example
let's say something like this what can
often take and then play on those on
those weak squares yeah II six is
believed to be the best setup and now
they usually castle where Bishop g5 is
also move after which Navarro plate
Queen to be six now this has been seen
before it's not a completely new idea
however after castles and nobody up to
this point dare to take the pawn which
navara did he just grabbed it and this
seems to be very very risky you know the
compensation that Dino gets is enormous
there's queen to d3 connecting looks and
allowing rupee one and also of course
the night was hanging so this was the
main thing yeah Queen back to be six
this is pretty much forced rupee one
twin 85 and now a very strong move by
ding he played Queen to d2 it's a tactic
coming up Knight takes d5 is the threat
so if black is playing some kind of non
move let's say he plays night
six then takes takes 95 is excellent the
queen is hanging and after Queen d2
that's 97 check King edge a to Bishop
chinks and now c6 will be dropping so
night XD 5p is an important tactical
trick so Navarro has to take care of
that and place the move King age 8 this
is to make sure that after this this
that there is no check King is out of
reach night xe5 their form is prevented
still White has a fantastic compensation
for this pawn and goes 9 p-5 had to take
Bishop takes and now we see ninety seven
and 96 white has a really scary
initiative for his young minimal
material investment 9 a-6 and 96 it
looks very critical King g8 was attacked
on f7 rook fc1 and Niobe 67 not much in
terms of alternatives yeah and I think
maybe around here we need to find an
improvement ding has an excellent
position but what to do how exactly to
play it yeah and the computers are not
entirely clear on what what they think
is best one suggestion is a form which
makes some sense just to attack that
pawn chain and the lights coming from
that do look very good for white we have
to admit that Bishop d7 for example then
a five it's a bishop a for you 398 this
could be an idea to get to get some some
some trades going get rid of that night
but what can actually jump to c8 quite
funny lights on the opponent's back
rancor always a funny funny
right yeah I can continue with Knight f6
maybe 97 check and now white getting the
porn bag and Knight to c6 also
interesting with also taking yeah white
it's a completely symmetrical pawn
structure but why it has the far more
active pieces and this configuration is
very very annoying yeah white certainly
has good chances to ya get this to win
even though it is not a force do we know
anything like that but I think that what
ding Liren played III this is probably
pretty much defect by Nevarez reply
which is very strong knigu form this is
the only move that gets black back into
the game it's it's really really a good
simplifying move yeah Bishop takes the
force plate we have to look at the
alternative Knight takes e4 after night
text before black is hacking of this
night that's very important and after
takes takes Bishop takes Bishop takes
root b 8 and the worst is definitely
over for black he will get in rook to
aid with the tempo and that night will
probably be activated on c5 in the
future p wyd is still somewhat better
him but it's definitely a far better
than what yeah what could have happened
to black I guess yeah this was also not
a bad try white is still having an
initiative but it seems that now after
this is returned the e4 pawn if now with
the Straits on the C file that black
should be able to hold reasonably
comfortably this was another important
move getting rid of upon the in the
center d5 only try for something group
the aid
let's III and no f5 her black tries to
play you for and undermine the whole
thing plus night before us an idea at
one point so II for it's the best tribe
and now just to capture isolating the D
porn and this deep on will be ultimately
won by black check couple of moves
elaborate check got everything traded
down check and here they agree to a draw
yeah a good defense here by Navarro he
played a very risky opening with Queen
b6 and Queen takes be too and probably
on that move eighteen around them we had
a critical moment when when III hear
that III move allowed the
simplifications with 94 and here's where
white probably has to improve a fourth
one idea Bishop g5 is also an idea I
couldn't really figure out what's what's
best yeah in that limited time but those
alternatives were certainly more testing
that III after which navara equalized
okay so let's have a look at the game
Wesley so caruana American duel or do
all of the new Americans let's say um in
Italian game so not what we could expect
there but yeah it is a frequent let's
say secondary option if people are tired
of the roof so why not end it earlier in
the vent led to a good win by kayaking
with white against thomashefsky so got
this d3d 6c 386 rookie one Bishop a
seven so koala is shooting for what is
now arguably the modern main line of
that of that opening here the JUCO piano
yeah this is also what I play
with a six Bishop a seven yeah a for now
by wesley is so pretty quickly played um
and now Bishop is six played by caruana
this is technically speaking a novelty
the idea whatever is of course very well
known and I usually play Bishop e6 a
little bit later after having castled
and often castle like rookie aid but
should be six in that that kind of way
but there's nothing wrong with that the
difference is that there are some
specific things now with P 786 hanging
but black can cover that the whole
position was totally fine for ya for
both sides of fur but also for black
completely fine here with c5 there is
however one very critical moment Cara
wanna know plexiform that's an
interesting interesting try and before
was played what we should look at what
else is there what happens if why it
takes on e5 black hands Nyjah form
interesting interesting idea and after
the remove the rook moves let's say 2 e
2 then maybe night takes d5 this is an
interesting situation this is in some
some way yeah limiting widescreen and
night and blackheads idea like Quincy
five and put some pressure on f2 it
looks decent from black white went
before TX takes completely different
idea and now um kawana plate do you play
that c4 and look eone yeah this is a
critical position now because now kawana
makes a mistake really a technical
mistake and after that he has to suffer
for the whole game and the game will
take a long long time it seems that um
the move t5 is good here even though the
ensuing complications are somewhat
somewhat computer ish
in some cases well not not so much but
it's um it's stronger at least where
it's what kawana played if Y chicks here
it's easy like is fine after night XD
for the more interesting tribe he has a
move like 90 to c5 and in this case and
complications come up after p6 for
example d takes Knight takes Knight
takes be takes and I think it's probably
roughly equal a d5 move is quite
complicated yeah white can also try to
take here but after this again Black is
fine so 95 is probably the move however
what kawana did is 96 and this is a has
a technical issue night c5 now it was
pretty strong attacking the knight
x-raying is 6 and attacking e6 so
there's not much choice he had to take
it and now Quincy form yeah and this
leads by my force to a problematic
position for black black cannot take
here as 95 rook takes oops rook takes e4
is winning nice little nice little point
check check and the Queen gets lost so
what's blacks supposed to do he has to
take with on d4 pawn takes a again
Knight takes e4 doesn't work due to the
same tactic as shown before so we had to
play something like that 97 and now
after a 5 black is really in some
trouble you know why it has much better
centralized pieces Lucani one and he's
getting with d5 is getting a dangerous
person like has to be very careful in
defending this but karana did an
excellent job we have to say he's under
huge pressure and finds basically a ton
of yeah good moves only moves and
the very strong defensive play the C
porn here is used as a decoy what black
wants to do is ideally trade all the
queenside pawns and this is what you
ultimately managed here b5 takes takes
Queen it back and now check because of
all this always trade it and this end
game is again it's not fun I mean it's
absolutely not fun for black but he
managed to hold that ultimately yeah
this is one of those games i think i
could have looked a little bit deeper
but i didn't really happen um gap the
intention to make this video even longer
and it seems that there is no clear
where you had to improve at any stage
they also tried the night end game but
here black ultimately held champion even
that position chan chan we can there of
course always little trick so here's
something like this can be held by over
this move yeah it is a draw it really is
a girl they chant chant laid on a little
bit more chanting the way or lonely or
not i tried no no hear that stopped move
18 yeah so a little bit of a
disappointment probably for Wesley so he
had pressure the whole game and it felt
like close to breaking down but there
was no clear moment where some
improvement forum for so was apparent so
yeah at the end at the end of draw they
both have a good standing in this event
and yeah cannot be blamed for fighting
spirit 80 Moses is good stuff so um what
next kind of losing track here
yeah let's go with we found with white
against why he my notes are complete
mess here yeah and for this game let me
note that I mostly may look at the
ending a little bit we had had an anti
goon felt yeah who you found it's very
flexible in this event she plays all
kinds of openings that she does not
usually play as mostly an e4 player but
he or she has played 93 and all kinds of
closed systems where he also took some
minutes IAM adjusting to the situation
so this is the line that i have played
myself a little bit in the past and
always felt that white has some slide
some chances for slide pool because yeah
classical values and white has an extra
porn in the center a little bit more
space it looks okay yeah and it was
quite interesting here with f5 what what
he did and we see that he has spent a
huge amount of time early only in this
game and some tribe time travel was
looming yeah now interesting play by
buyer who you find she gives up the 8 to
pawn quite interesting but s
compensation she has very good control
away 5 and ideas here with h4 so white
has a definite initiative and for the
pawn I don't want to look at this in
much detail as I said yeah why does
pushing you on the edge file and
centralizes who night very nice position
yeah don't treat queens not so much
because of the trade itself it you don't
want to get a pawn here I mean this is
horrible because black gets a pawn to
kick the night out and so queens are
kept on the board and now Bishop b4
tough decision you had to wreck the pawn
store
like that but it was probably a decision
also influenced by the reduced time to
simplify things a little bit yahoo gauge
for in 95 here yahoo gauge for might be
a little bit yeah might be questionable
pre near six was an idea here yeah
things are very very tough after that
something like age 16 g 8 look at form
queen g5 this looks like black is in
decent shape this is hanging this is
hanging things are very complicated
though even group takes a 5 has an idea
here yeah leading to quite crazy play
takes takes root be friday check and
this kind of position why this all of a
sudden coming from here yeah the night
is pretty strong here yeah it's a very
very difficult position why he went for
95 he was down to two minutes 22 and now
we've got the Queen's traded yeah this
end game that we get is probably around
equal yeah white is getting the porn
back and the black pawn structure is
compromised but the counter playing for
black here with the active rook and
possibility sometimes against be too
should compensate for that a bit there
is however one moment and it's here when
my egos for c5 and this is a very
aggressive active move and it meant was
played with 30 seconds on the clock or
something like that so we shouldn't be
too critical there but I feel like this
is playing with fire a little bit and
blacks pawn structure is worsened again
he's doing that for activity of course
it wasn't just some random move but it
gets very critical and we found played
this now 93 it seems to be that the
capture could be an improvement
it's complicated though of course not
you can King bee 395 king before the
King gets very active and something like
that is probably better for white even
though things are still as I said not
clear-cut mostly because of black always
having some kind of play with this
threat of getting the beep on and this
makes the beef up on quite dangerous
it's not just about counting points here
yeah something like Gucci five hats a
king age seven there's no clear-cut way
for white forward you have to take care
of that pawn okay she played Knight f3
and I look a one was played my computer
gives rook be one with an interesting
little point the point is that after
this this takes there's a strong move
nachi for typical computer ish go play
with black all of a sudden having this
and equalizing yeah but no one plays
that with 30 seconds on the clock ooh k
1 also looks fairly logical she now took
chennai default check king c2 yeah and
now um where you probably had to take on
c5 with the night that position seems
better for white but things are not
totally clear like this for example and
now rook e1 trying to go for counter
play again with the beep on something
like that say be three um check KD 1 and
rugby too is not entirely clear yeah
white looks good with a structure but
that'd be point is dangerous King is
however near it I'm not entirely sure
this is what he had to do at least with
black what he did rook a five this is
getting close to the edge of being lost
due to this strong reply there's this 96
which makes rooks if I unplayable after
King III hangs and 96 yeah so 95 had to
be played and here now is a tough
decision really tough decision and yeah
white also was down to a very little
time by now um the principal choice is
between playing the Muji form which is
what she did fixing that weakness and
it's not bad at all I'm just saying this
is the first principle sure the second
one is not to be three which forces the
nice trade um this is just a very good
endgame for white now we have to be
perfectly clear them that is probably
getting lost and white has the far
better structure definitely worth
considering but the Wu Chi form was not
bad at all 94 and now night f5 check
that does not spoil the wind even though
f3 was probably easier every night back
and King III looks excellent wyd
structures very good this pawn is going
to fall Black has no counter play that
looks like a win still some work but it
should win ok ok now I have five check
and now it's move 40 so the final move
there by years to play quickly and King
f7 now seems to seems to be better than
king of 6 which is very tough to spot
yeah this is what the engine is giving
check oops check a king here um
sorry King g6 I'm sorry yeah and the
funny thing is that rookie 7 rooks e5
check isn't that great actually because
this is both falling so look HD is
better now back and now f3 and again why
does some close to winning but black is
fighting after King f6 things are even
worse because after a 395 h6 and yeah
black basically gasps condemned to step
forward yeah ruge f7 King f7 also didn't
help so King e5 and that poem was
falling okay one check and check Andrew
h5 quite logical you're getting to the
g5 porn check be three chick gives you
three kings 26 yeah and here we have a
moment where white now could have won
the game pretty clearly yeah it's one of
the clearer options and what she did
probably also yeah I don't know I'm not
sure actually this does win this is I'm
pretty clear about that this does win
yeah Black has to go to be five anything
else that's a king to d6 we just take
this and we are happy yeah there is no
counter play yes saying something like
that is the end of any hopes you know
why it has this thread and black is not
getting any play because he doesn't get
to pawn this is the thing Black has to
get the pawn on be true to get
counter-plan this is not happening here
so the King had to go to be five
something like that doesn't help okay
King to be five oops I'm sorry thing to
be five and what's the point now this is
the point with 93 why this forcing the
the night straight enter that makes
things quite simple takes takes
this is hanging King before yeah now
just one more moment if Y takes now then
check all of a sudden things turn around
completely the other be point is super
dangerous what white has to do is to
play rook to h2 just cover the
second-ranked and then go up and use the
pawns this should be pretty simple win
okay rook g5 or else played and after
that I am not clear I'm absolutely not
sure if white can still win this game
King b5 and here what's the final
opportunity to try even though this is
entailed some risk the engine gives
Knight to f4 and I'm absolutely not sure
what this leads to something like Roxy
one is critical check yeah what has to
go up there to try to win and now night
a form and this is the kind of variation
if you see that beforehand you feel like
okay maybe I'm winning but maybe I'm
also losing yeah because if their pawn
drops this is pretty quick so absolutely
unsure what happens here engines like
white but I mean not like plus 5 or
something just plus 0.8 but what to make
of that assessment him I'm very unsure
him if this is a real winning
opportunity or not can only be I think
determine if you look at this with much
more time on your hands what she did
ultimately was to just take the night
and get to this hand game and this is a
drone I mean it looks great you have
three points for the exchange but the
points are simply drop yeah you don't
get to do much with them yeah why does
also not in any danger of course check
Josh you got to be a moment yeah he
drove us agreed so ultimately a
disappointment I think
for the former women world champion she
had a very good game and had clear
winning chances there probably had a win
in one or two situations that were
pretty straightforward even though it
was never something trivial something
easy that you would say okay well she
has to see that it was tricky it was
really tricky okay next game is Giri
Mammadyarov let's go now got a Catalan
no II for you as well yeah and this line
here by Mammadyarov this is not very
common but has um yeah has caught some
momentum in recent yet say two or three
years Bishop e7 is the more unusual move
but Bishop d6 has some interesting ideas
black quite often wants to play taxi 697
and it could be five I'm give a set up
against it is actually interesting I've
never seen this this early be three year
but it kind of fits into whites plans
yeah um here mamma jamma of now goes for
a structural change that i think is
strategically quite risky he took one
see form there were alternatives like b6
for example um but okay he took in
plenty five the problem with this is
that after e3 what give me played it's
very difficult for black to get his
Queen side developed that bishop on C
aid and and the rook then it's a
diagonal is open there you have a hard
time to get this organized an important
point is that after C takes why did not
take with the porn after pawn takes
black is fine but of course took with
the night yeah that poor Nia that
weakish looking porn is no problem at
all how more interesting is that the
diagonal is open
and black now is pretty much forced to
play a 6 as know I'd be five is annoying
so a six Luke see one this is very
supporting the sea porn good move and
now rooty aid was played yeah and now
after night be three you have to answer
some questions with black what about
Bishop a5 what about pawn to c5 yeah
here it seems that muhammad arif
probably should have played Bishop to e5
leading to interesting play yeah there
are a couple of options they have Bishop
a five for example black and gold b6 and
after Bishop a8 Bishop to a-1 ready for
a weird stuff yeah Flex position seems
to be okay an alternative for white as
he m to simply sacrifice a pawn that's
possible Bishop c3 for example we have
Queen takes and Queen B to black
definitely has to be um yeah very
precise in defending this because white
still has the far better bishop and the
Queen side has trouble developing this
is probably what Nora of should have
gone for Bishop b5 I guess what he
played is rupee eight and after that it
gets difficult already i think c5 now 94
hmm and this position i absolutely
dislike for black i'm not quite sure how
it's going to untangle them one issue is
that any be porn movies always answered
by 96 and yeah yeah 96 or what happened
in the game points and six any tribe b6
I don't know I don't know what is what
you should do when white hands very easy
further movie on night can sometimes go
here and here on night 2 a-4 I mean what
play is pretty simple and
even got some choice while black is yeah
defending them engines give this move
but after 93 I have six and something
like Knight takes pawn things and c6
white is also a lot better yeah that's
simply not a good position I want you
yeah this was tried and now c6 now that
porn is enormous down 9 f8 when just 93
yeah black has a hard time to take the
pawn on d4 if he wants to do that
something like that looks bad I mean
black has big problems moving anything
let's say nine to six in this position
route d1 Jac's cakes and black is
running out of moves here something like
h6 for example I just place in this
fashion 28 is coming and then c7 yeah I
just like us playing without to wear too
much too many pieces 96 was played and
rupee 10 just in Priam increasing the
pressure again black could not really
take him it gives too much compensation
for wide again this annoying move is
pretty strong yeah the queen is seven is
what Mammadyarov tried but um this is
giving the exchange I think I mean he
saw that of course but he probably felt
like either you get in this or you give
up the exchange just to get get pieces
out there however the resulting position
is probably close to a win for white and
yeah maybe it is a wind with good
technical play here nice little moment
um gimme could have taken on f7 but he
decided against that
as Bishop a 8 it's looking somewhat
scary for a human eye the engines are
completely ruthless of course and think
that white should win he am probably
true but still with those light squares
don't need you don't need that as wide
so King takes and he just played this
position there with an actual exchange
um yeah I don't want to look at the
technical part of this game to be honest
it it takes a while but why it is an
exchange up and black hands no
compensation was a jar of tried to muddy
the waters a little bit depth but
ultimately it didn't it didn't lead to
anything he give you already could have
traded Queens which he didn't something
like this and rookie one is pretty
convincing but um there were many many
ways to to win this game and he found
one that it was clear enough that same
yeah here Bishop t2 for example also was
winning and a bit quicker maybe than
what he did he did that sorry I almost
one moment here this this wasn't really
necessary it ultimately leads to a piece
a position that should win gently
fast-forwarding here those all those
moves ok get in tier my jar of results
yes no no way to stop that born from
getting lost and wide still has
therefore porn so there is no rook plus
Bishop where the Sun Varrick coming up
which leaves us with cardinals game and
yeah let's load that Carlton
thomashefsky
okay so what did we have in this game
yes a London sister that one a thriller
yeah actually they came God interesting
so don't stop the video just yet yeah
cardenas even a tournament chess going
for the London system now in there and
yeah let's see what happens tomorrow ski
goes b6 and yeah please reasonably
quickly in the opening it doesn't seem
to be totally surprised but starting
around here I have some I don't know
okay he plays 96 which is of course it
cannot be bad yeah but I'm not a huge
fan of that setup if you start like that
I really feel like black should go for
some kind of d6 base setup maybe this is
just Mia yeah promoting the system that
that I like I usually try to take on the
form here and after ed takes play d 6
and play head shock I think this is a
very good set up against the London
where white has absolutely nothing I'm
not saying that white as much after that
but I feel like at least here then d6
and 95 mean it's not bad for black yeah
but if you want to go for this structure
I really think you should start with
with this kind of setup and not
fianchetto in the first place and put
the bishop on d6 this is a fairly fairly
good equalizing system and here black
has BN cathode which is not strictly
necessary and he takes two moves for
Bishop t6 the position is of course um
yeah quiet and slowish so it's not that
this is a dramatic thing but yeah I feel
White has gotten a little bit more than
was necessary yeah cancel now plays a
move rook f 2 e 1 which is just a
waiting roof
asking black what is what he wants to do
um interesting is to to check the
captures now if black takes here and
here this seems to lead to a pretty
decent position for white the thing is
said after Knight takes Knight takes
pawn takes white structure is not
looking pretty but this bishop will stay
bad for quite a while so an interesting
position that Carlton probably was very
satisfied with if he would have gotten
it um yeah black also can take on F form
but not take on d4 it's also possible
takes takes rook c8 after which probably
something that Queenie 3 is a decent
this is not an boring position you know
why it has ideas there with 95 coming
and so on yeah Tomashevsky plate 97
after a long thought and regroup the
night to g6 and now card the solution is
very interesting very unconventional I
think yeah he took that and it took that
night hey the thing is it's also a
little bit like what else yeah if white
is not doing that and goes for for this
for example you really wonder where the
ideas are ya black might play 94 soonish
and then d5 so this is maybe a case of
you have to do it to get to get some
kind of tension what is the tension he
actually takes takes takes and now this
this was the idea what gets a pretty
good night only five and this is also a
point with this pawn structure normally
like is quite happy with this and
because that double porn is helping yeah
to get some control near the center and
then at least you don't mind it so much
but with the night only five you have
one problem here you cannot easily play
the move f6 so if this this for example
and
black takes white Teague's yeah you
cannot play of six this night is
annoying and white has ideas yeah
sometimes just like g3 h4 h5 trying to
play on the edge file like has no good
counter player amazingly an interesting
strategic concept yeah Tomashevsky tried
something else he played the move g5 and
again that cards had a very interesting
recipe you played f4 and he played all
that very quickly Tomashevsky was
drifting into time travel after at four
he took that porn pretty much has to and
now we'll get one that was the the big
point yeah what is black supposed to do
now yeah if he takes only three the move
rook takes f6 Islam is the interesting
trial what happens here is that more
than a draw very very complicated
complicated stuff now if black takes on
d 2 then what definitely has a very
strong attack but is it is it more than
a draw yeah Queen h5 may is an option
but after takes d4 King h7 check we see
how it leads to a draw so it says some
alternative form for white right here
something else if white takes with the
Queen then black will take and now
probably 924 yeah this is still quite
interesting white has Rugare for ya
there are a couple of possibilities i'm
not quite sure what would have happened
after Luke takes f6 it takes I'm not
sure that that white is more than that
kind of a perpetual a try for white is
to just take the two and let this rook
yeah that's a group for up for the
taking if black takes then check check
check and drooped III as end of game so
the game continues from him and it's
tricky it's really tricky something like
Queen to e7 can be played and now maybe
just Rugare for continuing to attack
White is just one point down but he has
all pieces near the Kings side and yeah
that is that it's at least practically
very difficult for black not quite sure
what would have happened but it takes
takes on III was a very principled
decision thomashefsky played 90 to d7
and now after between H 5149 f6 yeah you
couldn't really take on e5 this is just
too simple and white gets a strong
attack without any material deficits so
Knight f6 is right I think the the
problem comes here well the problem
comes in like already has problems here
because he's under so much pressure and
he's down more than an hour on the clock
but it's clear that the next move is
costing too much chef ski the game let's
put it like that he here I think had to
take on deform you have take here first
and then the move night before that he
went for in the game um why does better
here after Queen a form but it is not
clear um if he if he can win let's say
it's so continues and it's not let's say
mathematical forced win or any of the
soul which is different after the
immediate 94 he was under pressure he
was an hour down the clock this is where
those mistakes happen yeah here um white
after night XD for is basically winning
black no took yeah if
you take here then queen age 5 and drew
cage for is killing immediately so Queen
trade night has to be taken and now the
problem is that after D takes c5 this is
why black should have taken on before in
the first place and only then play
94like now white is invading and yeah I
mean this looks bad at first sight but
it's really so bad that black is yeah
collapsing in a couple of moves he's
just he just has too many weaknesses so
if you try to get rid of the night
you're actually running into a self made
in five was played Roxy 7 a-4 just takes
yeah notice that cars didn't spend any
time on the game and was picking up
picking up stuff he's got more than one
hour left on the clock at the end of the
game um yeah pretty convincing win here
for the world champion with very
interesting play I think that was very
interestingly played that idea here with
Bishop g6 and then establishing the
night was very nice and this was a very
creative way of drumming up and attack
the critical muth was probably really to
take only three but it takes it takes
wow you have to be very principled
person to do that especially with little
time on the clock but the way it was
played it was very smooth sailing for
the world champion probably not very
difficult ultimately so Carlton with the
second win in a row I'm pretty I mean in
in last year's event he had a couple of
drawers then lost the game and then all
of a sudden 16 games in a row this time
he is sided with four drawers and now 12
games so he joined some the leaders of
the whole event which is ding Liren as
having 22 wins no losses Caruana is on +
2 +
no cards as well how I'm not forgetting
anybody no I don't think so i think this
is right we have those those three
players with plus two um yeah who you
found was very close to joining them
yeah she had a winning chance against
why he and she also had winning chances
against carwin I am she is certainly
probably the the biggest story of the
events of I guess having no problems at
all actually playing four winds on
getting near wins in many games ok I
hope you enjoyed the coverage of round
six I'll be back tomorrow or maybe on
Sunday morning my time with coverage of
round seven thanks for watching